oui mon battue alors dites moi quand
j'étais jeune en 5e je me serais
toujours de lui ça plaît antonin
commence ma tonnard des chars et ouais
antonin oui quand même et moi très jeune
mais ont dégénéré avec à l'âge d'isa
pour s'appeler anthony nom et de 5e
pareil donc on a un cinquième on a quoi
13 ans ouais sauf que moi j'étais assez
chétif jusqu'à l'âge de 16-17 a fait
plusieurs fois que vous nous le dites
oui absolument
et donc j'ai tendance est un peu tête de
turc et jamais je n'osais pas retourner
à l'école face et cette rentrée me
faisait peur mon père qui est de bon
conseil me dit dès le premier jour
shop le plus gros est costaud entonnant
l'occurrence tu lui rentrer dedans et
tout le reste de l'année comme en prison
tu seras respecter tout le temps il fait
de la prison non mais j'imagine j'ai vu
des films c'est un peu la loi du plus
fort d'accord
donc est ce que j'ai fait le premier
jour non non je suis allé là et bam
c'est là qu'ils ont pu discuter avec
quelqu'un ouais t'as pas monsieur
pouffant moi je suis passé j'ai fait ça
tunisie ou plus au [ __ ] gb sabam
ouais donc l'audi s'est retourné mais
ils savent pas mais là j'ai rien senti
donc
pourtant j'ai tout mairie alors je leur
fais mais prend pas ça pour une
démonstration de force assure je
m'excuse pas est haute et sortent en
effet gros one way alors là et comment
ils commencent à me dire tu va bousculer
il m'a bousculé ce que tu m'a bousculé
et là j'ai fait et qu'est ce ça peut te
[ __ ]
[Rires]
donc là c'est comme ça il est surpris
recul il est surpris oui alors il
fallait et je suis pas très costaud
comme ça c'est que ça peu de fruits oui
à tout le monde d'où ce qu'une antonin
c'était quand même et antonin artaud n'a
pas été le seul petit moment de ma
fierté est ce que là et après il est
revenu
ouais et je me serais toujours il est
arrivé le traitement il ne fait comme ça
parmi femmes
il m'a pris comme ça voilà il m'a baissé
comme à la maison
[Applaudissements]
après tu m'as pris par le cou comme dans
jury je vais le retrouver
elana qui m'a fait un truc horrible il
m'a fait ça comme ça et là paf non deux
comme ça géraldine maillet sais quoi
mais j'ai une photo de vous quand vous
étiez nicole regarder géraldine maillet
regardez-le géraldine maillet géraldine
maillet eddy maillet est franchement
elle est pas mort une tache sur eux
non non c'est pas une passion tous les
tous les enfants fait et tu vois pas
quelle tâche surtout les enfants espèces
d'or noir là partout pourquoi de nos
tâches a tonné me xavier une tâche pas
parce que j'avais un petit rituel comme
ça je les mets non mais tout le monde a
fait j'ai mis tout le monde pourquoi ils
pourront guincher pas si je me suis dit
ok t'es un peu fétichiste pour les
marckois sur la photo vous allez me
détache way et elle c'est une serial
killeuse enfant de la balle à des photos
aux états et donc et vous étiez très
mignonne ouest en scène un ca à gâteau
couche une photo de vous aussi
ah oui agathe regarder une photo minyana
des achats d'or 87
oui j'adore à gatineau richier on
classerait au vu des 90 m la coupe bien
que 17 j'avais dix-sept la meuf à 12 ans
moi c'est un truc de ouf
mais gilles vous qu'est ce qui s'est
passé nous sommes à l'automne 1961
nous sommes à l'automne 1972 et 8 ans à
la cour de mon école primaire et en
gravier nous sommes à villiers sur orge
dans l'essonne et oui il ya du gravier
et quand il y à du gravillon nous
interdit de jouer au foot mais mais moi
je ne peux pas m'empêcher à la
récréation que jouer au foot donc
j'amène bons ballons et je joue au foot
mais comme j'ai un problème de gestion
de la colère
est-ce que je joue au foot à ras terre
je donne des grands coups pour marquer
des buts comme un bourrin perets baba
c'est ce que vous êtes un e et l'autre
problème c'est que je casse 2 3 fois
même la vitre du bâtiment juste derrière
ouais et marius marius c'est l'homme
d'entretien cantonniers à l'époque qui
s'occupe de nous marius il prend mon
ballon mais ils me regardent vers des
îles très bons ballons il a bien fait
michel moreau lalala toutes été arrêtées
deux congos lui a non il a entre
l'époque des soupes lui donne accès non
mais c'est vrai vous aviez détenus sur
la nouvelle de ma mère on dirait et le
garçon et ses tubes où ça ah bah oui
mais c'est moi il n'y a que des garçons
c'est vrai c'est donc une infime parce
que lyon n'ait bernanke est il à daniel
morelon sous pull rouge
[Applaudissements]
il a bien fait le problème c'est que on
continue à jouer au foot moi j'amène le
ballon et c'est plus moi qui casse les
carreaux jamais j'ai arrêté mais les
carreaux continue d'être cassé non
vernet partie très bons ballons dit
marius c'est pas moi oui mais sait-on
ballon parti crève le ballon qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait un complot histoire rêve
les ballons même quand on joue au foot
parce que les carreaux sont cassés sais
pas vous mais non c'est plus moi malheur
compris je joue doucement juste marius à
l'époque il nous emmène à la cantine
ouais parce que la cantine une histoire
il nous emmène à l'extérieur à la
cantine mais est ce que j'ai fait
j'étais là en ce2 cm1 cm2 il faut jamais
le faire c'est méchant mais je vous
raconte que je suis honnête c'est qu'on
avait de la salade et quand marius qui
nous gardaient il allait garder comme ça
une autre table ou voir un gros mot
l'art non un vrai gouvernement des
années je m'excuse auprès de marius
aujourd'hui j'en profite je suis gémeaux
près de la rue marius j'aurais jamais dû
faire ça
savais tu m'entends ce thème et depuis
on a des nouvelles de marc ysaye on
embrasse il est ouvert une brasserie
mollard on a pour se détendre on a une
photo de classe de vous c'est une diapo
en noir et blanc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
certains d'entre vous reconnaîtront les
grottes de lascaux
[Rires]
il adore ça vaut d'être mignonne aouedj
est adorable y'a vraiment vraiment cette
magnifique à regarder on a eu nos
devinez qui sait regarder derrière c'est
qui ça gilles aussi la cgil vers des
aires
ah ouais il avait déjà il avait une tête
de l'entrée l'accusé a normalement c'est
une photo celle là tu la vois que donc
remake jours
[Applaudissements]